we we should we should feel good we
should feel proud we should feel it's
fun to be recognized it's fun for people
to sort of admire or hate you
at the same time be successful yeah yeah
you know I mean that's a good feeling
that's pride yeah but nobody hates you
I've looked on Internet is nothing
nobody hates you I just stay low-key man
I don't know I don't was that what Oh DJ
means off the grid yeah yeah yeah you're
a very weird guy in that way like you
you live in Colorado yeah Colorado we
grew up there we grew up about three
years there I went to school there I
took the kids last year to Colorado for
a year and a half then we did this wait
wait you grew up there too yeah in high
school elementary school Wow with what
was Kurt Kurt took us there Kurt had a
place there and he took our family there
for the first time it's so funny because
we had on our podcast so see bacon um
Kevin Bacon they don't yeah she was a
month ago we had her and in many ways
her parents because have you told me
about how your parents raised you mmm
her parents were the same kind of way
you know like a lot of kids that grew up
you know with famous parents and whatnot
they turn [ __ ] up yeah you know me
they're drug addicted or they have
tattoos on their face something weird
and yeah right but this guy's like so
like rounded and they never gave you
anything right right and they pay
attention to you a lot of these a lot of
you know they just it's about just being
present paying attention to you raising
your children as if you know how you
were raised and my parents came from
nothing and so they we had a lot yeah
well that's what you told me that they
both right grew up with nothing oh yeah
my mom moved to New York when she was 19
she had a dance studio you know she
taught little girls how to dance do
ballet that she was she wasn't even
planning on being an actress she wanted
to dance and do musicals and that was
all she wanted to do and then she was
discovered at the World's Fair and in
New York and sort of the rest is history
she she did laugh-in and that bubbly
crazy she was like so likable right yeah
yeah she left laughing to do a movie
called Sugarland Express no sorry cactus
flower
first movie and she won an Academy Award
and it was a dramatic movie Wow so that
was that was it you know that's it
that's it
then Private Benjamin all that star bang
yeah yeah that's that's that's that's
amazing but yes so we had a lot
Christmases four great we want a great
vacation there's no doubt about it you
know yeah but inside the house inside
the walls of our home who was it was not
any different you know what I mean as
far as raising a child goes why we were
not given everything we were not given
hundreds of dollars for allowance if we
even had allowance yeah we got I got
spanked and my mom my mom spanked me
many times yeah and it was for the it
was for the little things it was
interesting because I got arrested when
I was 15 years old for paintballing okay
with Halloween Halloween I we went shot
up these people and caught it was
horrible you know but it was fun and we
got arrested
we got hauled off into jail and it's
actually a funny story because we're all
sitting in the waiting room there and I
said okay we're gonna call your parents
and they picked me say okay what's your
dad's name can you start with somebody
else ya know what's your father's name
yeah you know I'm like Kurt Russell
they're like shut the [ __ ] up and I'm
like my dad's name is Kurt Russell like
yours really that means your mother's
Goldie Hawn isn't yes this is the fact
yeah and they start fighting over who's
gonna make the phone call one dude was
like one dude was like I arrested him
and the other guy was like he wrote in
my car I mean it was like they actually
had a bit of a fight I mean who was so
Kurt comes into the thing he P shows up
oh yeah oh my god oh dude live it it was
no good was he livid he was teeth were
clenched his face was red oh my god and
they gave us back our paintball guns
because we were allowed to have them oh
yeah it was like they're not his guns
and I'm like they're not my guns and the
cops were like you can take them we
don't want them
they're not your guns I'm like they're
not my god I don't know how to be had
some plan anyway my punishment was he
didn't scream at me my punishment was I
had to shoot up my car because I just
got a new my first car and I shoot up my
car like close friends with my paintball
gun and dent oh so my point is yeah is
that he doesn't get mad for those things
because he gives me the benefit of the
doubt that I know what I did wrong
there's no reason to say you know what
the [ __ ] because you get it you're smart
enough to know that you were an [ __ ]
in this situation right the next day we
were going to school my sister had her
backpack that I had used to put my
paintball [ __ ] in she comes to me and
she goes Olli give me my backpack
unloaded and I'm like I'll do it later
or whatever she goes and tells on me my
dad kind of Kirk comes over he goes
Ollie backpack take the [ __ ] out give it
back to Kate I'm like I'll do it later
cocky getting arrested right yeah he
lost his [ __ ] rightfully so yeah you
know what I mean yeah and so those are
the times when I got in trouble when I
got yelled at and screamed at and all
that yeah when I the little things that
I didn't recognize and those are the
things that if they go left unchecked
that's when you become an [ __ ] in
your 20s and 30s you feel like entitled
and you can do anything the [ __ ] you
want yeah they made sure that we knew
that when we were [ __ ] we were we
knew about it all of us all the kids did
they when they you said I want to become
an actor was I mean yeah I didn't want
to be an actor I didn't start acting
till it's 20 21 I wanted to make movies
that's what I did I've directed movies
with my friends and Kate was acting
doing her plays and I would make movies
on the weekends oh wow yeah and then
acting I went to college for two years I
went to Boulder done with that piayed
for two years and then I said my whole
family does it I'll try it yeah I wanted
to act in class but I was I was horrible
man I was hungover going to auditions
not reading the sides and yeah living at
home you know I had no reason to [ __ ]
make anything of myself so I decided to
move out of my house with not a lot of
money I got an apartment that was
weighing over my head I could afford
three months of rent that's it I wanted
to put the pressure on myself say okay
I'm getting out of the house now you
know look to be fair my parents weren't
gonna let me [ __ ] live on the street
I knew I had my house you know sometime
not coming in here sounding like an ass
I knew what was happening but for me
personally I wanted to do that and it
worked I got a I got my first show on
The WB called my guide to becoming a
rock star was they had lead of the show
and you know Wow yeah so amazing yeah
it's my little story in a nutshell
[Music]